[Music]
mr. president
mr. Provost madam secretary
Dean's college heads college Dean's
colleagues friends families and most of
all members of the class of 2018 welcome
to this day
[Applause]
I now call on the University chaplain
good afternoon
please join me in the spirit of Prayer
Almighty and loving God you are the one
who gives us this day and all our days
in the majesty of this life moment we
your beloved children of different
colors Creed's generations stories and
tongues are gathered in this place as
one human family United in jubilant
celebration we are filled with gratitude
for our families friends teachers and
guides their arms have sheltered us
their shoulders have boosted us and
today their hearts soar for us eternal
God it is you who calls us to our full
humanity as we celebrate our
accomplishments we are humbled and
overwhelmed by what lies ahead
steady us so that we may continue to
caress the beauty of your creation let
our souls know true delight as we awaken
to the Wonder and mystery of our own
unfolding lives through unity of mind
and spirit hold us ever close as we seek
to live in your world wisely in
steadfast pursuit of your light and your
truth amen
oh that which pervades earth sky and
heaven which is worthy of worship that
has no beginning that which is the light
of wisdom and truth let us meditate on
the radiance of this divinity may that
brilliance help inspire and illuminate
our minds that one which represents
water light and is the quintessence of
all things may that Almighty spirit
pervading the earth atmosphere and
heaven bless us with enlightenment
send forth your light and your truth
they will lead me they will bring me
into your holy mountain to your dwelling
place that I may come to the altar of
God God might delight my joy that I may
praise you with the harp Oh God
my god
you are the light of the world a city
built on a hill cannot be hid no one
after lighting a lamp puts it under the
bushel basket but on the lamp stand and
it gives light to all in the house in
the same way let your light shine before
others so that they may see your good
works and give glory to your God in
heaven God is the light of the heavens
and earth
the likeness of his light is that of a
niche in which there is a lamp the lamp
is in a glass the glass is as it were a
brilliant star lit from a blessed tree
an olive tree neither of the East nor of
the West whose oil seems to glow even
though no fire has touched it light upon
light God guides whom He wills to his
light God makes parables for Humanity
and God has knowledge of everything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
on this occasion it is customary for the
president to deliver a baccalaureate
address and for the Dean of Yale College
to offer readings this is a historic
year for you it's the first time in its
history that the graduating class by
which I mean you includes members of 14
residential colleges two of them new and
one newly retic rededicated the
namesakes of those three new colleges
almost as though they had anticipated
this moment had words for you all
Benjamin Franklin we all know as a
polymath whose accomplishments span the
arts the sciences government and public
service among his prolific writings he
introduced what may be one of the first
self-help books in American history an
autobiography listing the virtues that
he wanted to perfect in himself for a
better life here are my favorites which
I offer to the ten of you who did not
take professor Laurie Santos his class
psychology and the good life
temperance eat not to dullness drink not
to elevation it's a little too late for
that
order let all your things have their
places let each part of your business
have its time resolution resolve to
perform what you ought perform without
fail what you resolve frugality make no
expense but to do good to others or
yourself
waste nothing industry lose no time be
always employed in something useful cut
off all unnecessary actions sincerity
use no hurtful to see think innocently
and justly and if you speak speak
accordingly moderation avoid extremes
forbear resenting injuries so much as
you think they deserve justice
wrong none by doing injuries or by
omitting the benefits that are your duty
Pauli Murray distinguished herself as a
leader for civil rights and the
Advancement of women president salivate
will say more about her but here I will
show a quote reported by Yale history
professor Glenda Gilmore who documented
Polly Murray's purposeful struggles
Murray was rejected from the University
of North Carolina because of her race
she was denied admission to Harvard Law
School because of her sex and she was
arrested in Virginia because she refused
to move to the back of a Greyhound bus
well after becoming the first African
American to receive a degree from Yale
Law School in an interview for the
southern Oral History Program in 1976
Pauli Murray offered these words about
her activism I would like to say here if
you will notice that the questions
you've been asking me about my
activities and the things that I was
involved in that in not a single one of
these little campaigns
was i victorious in other words in each
case I personally failed but I have
lived to see the thesis upon which I was
operating vindicated and what I very
often say is that I've lived to see my
lost causes found finally Grace Hopper
was a trailblazing computer scientist
and mathematician applying her analytic
skills to serve the country during World
War two after which she retired as a
Rear Admiral of the u.s. Navy Hopper was
less interested in safe careers as she
was in adventurous projects and in time
she developed some of the earliest
computers and pioneered computer
languages and compilers to run them here
she is in her own words humans are
allergic to change they love to say
we've always done it this way I try to
fight that that's why I have a clock on
my wall that runs counterclockwise the
second quote a ship in port is safe but
that is not what ships are for sale out
to sea and do new things class of 2018
congratulations
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
graduates of the class of 2018 family
members and friends it's a pleasure to
be here with you today a day filled with
joy for the present and hope for the
future there is a wonderful Yale
tradition that I would like to honor
right now may I ask all of the families
and friends here today to rise and
recognize the outstanding and graduating
members of the class of 2018
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well that was enthusiastic may I now ask
the class of 2018 to consider from a
moment all those who have supported your
arrival at this milestone and please
rise and recognize them
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you these are the months and years
when people tend to make a lot of plans
some are practical these scheduled
flights and rent apartments to consider
well where you will live work or study
after graduation others are more
aspirational you imagine your future
life and what you wish to accomplish in
the years ahead I want to begin by
sharing a passage Polly Murray wrote in
1945 about her aspirations at the time
she was a young lawyer and civil rights
activist here's the quotation I intend
to destroy segregation by positive and
embracing methods Murray wrote when my
brothers try to draw a circle to exclude
me I shall draw a larger circle to
include them where they speak out for
the privileges of a puny group
I shall shout for the rights of all
mankind so I ask you how large will you
draw your circle will you draw a circle
that is large inclusive and vibrant or
will it be small puny and privileged the
work of inclusion is difficult but the
rewards are great
let me suggest ways you might follow the
example of Polly Murray and many other
Yale graduates when you leave campus
first make sure your circles are truly
large in today's world where you can
have 700 followers on Twitter and a
thousand friends on Facebook it may seem
easy to have a large circle but if
you're bombarded with the same stories
the same memes and the same opinions
from all your so-called friends then
your world may in fact be quite narrow a
conversation with six friends in real
life actually may lead to a greater
variety of ideas and perspectives in my
years at Yale I've been provoked
privileged to know some of the most
brilliant minds in the world I've
learned that the greatest scholars draw
the largest circles they read widely and
are interested in ideas well beyond the
scope of their own research and their
own beliefs Robert Dahl who was a
sterling professor of political science
taught at Yale for 40 years one of the
most respected political scientists of
his generation
professor Dahl was an authority on
democracy and on democratic institutions
and he was a beloved teacher and mentor
after his death in 2014 at the age of 98
tributes from his former students poured
in one of his graduate students Geoffrey
Isaac recalled how he via mentally
disagreed with some of dollz arguments
even though he loved taking his class
for his dissertation Isaac proposed
writing a critique of dolls theories
much to his surprise the most
enthusiastic and supportive member of
the faculty in the Department of
Political Science was Dahl himself he
agreed to supervise the dissertation
Isaac wrote Bob doll spent countless
hours in his office talking with me
about my principal theoretical
antagonists him we would discuss this
guy doll in the third person we consider
the limits of his arguments we'd
speculate about how he might respond to
my arguments professor doll embraced his
critics listen to them and conversed
with them a model of open and engaged
scholarship and teaching the best we can
aspire to it Yale the lesson extends
beyond our campus our greatest
challenges as a society climate change
poverty insecurity violence demand
innovative and creative solutions yet
political polarization is making it more
difficult than ever to solve these
problems we must be able to talk with
our opponents even though we disagree
with them we might start by emulating
Professor Dahl and so many other wise
and generous thinkers who have drawn
large circles and so added to the sum of
human understanding my second piece of
advice and here I'm taking some
liberties with the metaphor is to draw
as
any circles as you can one circle will
be your work make sure you enjoy it but
make sure you have other circles as well
we know one of the keys to happiness is
developing a passion even an expertise
outside of work sharing that passion
with others gives us great joy and it
connects us to circles of friends and
associates who might be very different
from the ones we would meet otherwise as
many of you are aware I am quite
passionate about music from the
Appalachian Mountain region my love of
traditional country and bluegrass music
has allowed me to visit places such as
Southwest Virginia and Eastern Kentucky
it has allowed me to chair the board of
the International Bluegrass Music Museum
and to play bass for 30 years now with
the professors of bluegrass it enables
me to share stories and songs with
perfect strangers at summer time
bluegrass music festivals most
significantly though it has led to
circles of friendships beyond the towns
in which I grew up beyond the
universities I attended and beyond my
profession of psychology I'm of course
proud to be a psychologist and my
discipline in fact does provide
empirical evidence to support my
personal experience
Patricia Linville is a social
psychologist who studies how people
think of themselves and how these self
perceptions influence well-being she is
now at Duke but she was my teacher here
at Yale when she completed several
studies of what she terms self complex
city greater self complexity according
to Linville means a person has many
aspects of themselves in other words
they draw many circles for example a
woman who thinks of herself as a student
a marathon runner a theater goer a
reader of The New Yorker magazine and
let's say a bass player in the bluegrass
band would demonstrate greater self
complexity than someone who thinks of
himself only as a lawyer
professor Linville in her research found
that the great that greater self
complexity acts as a buffer against
negative experiences for example if you
define yourself almost entirely in terms
of your job getting passed over for a
promotion might be devastating for your
sense of self-worth linville calls this
putting all your eggs in one cognitive
basket people such as our marathon
running bass player on the other hand
bounce back more quickly after a setback
Linville even found that college
students with greater self complexity
were less likely to get sick or
experienced depression or stress third
and finally let me suggest one important
way we can expand our circles by
reaching out and engaging with others
here I would look like to turn again to
Polly Murray and one of her more
surprising relationships Murray's papers
contain thousands of letters a
reflection of a full life animated by
many interests commitments and many
relationships a life of many circles
during her time at Yale Law School
Murray received a letter from William as
spy Nicky a member of the Yale College
class of 1936 now that name will sound
familiar to everyone here the by Nicky
Rare Book and Manuscript library is
named for William's father and two
uncles and many other programs and
places at Yale have benefited from the
family's remarkable philanthropy bill by
Nicky passed away just last month he was
nearly 104 years old
in fact Tuesday is his birthday in 1963
when he wrote Murray he was chairman of
the Sperry and Hutchinson company a
venerable American company founded by
his grandfather your parents and
grandparents may remember SNH Green
Stamps Mary Ann Hutchinson Meineke was a
leader in corporate America and a
wealthy and powerful man he had met
Murray at an event at Yale and not long
after that he wrote her a letter he
enclosed a clipping from Time magazine
about race relations in the United
States and he asked Murray what she
thought Murray responded a few weeks
later he sent her another article and
asked her opinion again this time about
school integration she wrote back at one
point Murray wrote by Niki of four page
single spaced typed letter on what she
called the imponderables on the issue of
race their correspondence continued for
weeks
with interesting and frank letters on
both sides
by Nikki and Marie both exemplars of the
Yale tradition were able to sustain a
conversation despite differences in
gender differences in family background
differences in race differences in class
and much more we don't know whether or
not they entirely agreed with one
another but we can imagine they learned
a lot from the exchange all because two
individuals decided to reach beyond
their normal circles by turkeys decision
to write Marie did not take place in a
vacuum in the 1950s he attended a
discussion at Yale Law School on the
topic of American race relations not
long after he decided to look into
Sperry and Hutchinson's hiring practices
he learned that the employment agency
vetting applications for his company was
screening out african-americans removing
them from the pool before their
applications ever reached Sperry in
Hutchinson by Nikki ended the practice
he also supported scholarships for
underprivileged high school students and
established a fellowship for students of
color at Yale Law School it was in the
course of this work that he met Murray
and initiated their correspondence
hoping to bridge the gulf that separated
his experience from hers bill by Nikki's
life was made up of different circles
he led efforts to improve New York's
Central Park
he supported environmental causes he was
dedicated to the game of golf and he
remained an ardent champion of Yale and
its students among other interests
and what about Polly Murray who has a
young person promised to draw a larger
circle in her life
one month after writing her last letter
to Bill by Nikki she participated in the
historic march on Washington which she
helped organize
well while finishing her Doctor of
Jurisprudence degree here at Yale she
drafted an influential legal memo
helping to ensure that sex was included
in the Civil Rights Act of 1964 Murray's
other circles included writing poetry
and teaching at the age of 67 she became
the first african-american woman
ordained as an Episcopal priest
continuing her lifelong commitment to
reconciliation and understand enlarging
her circles is far from easy it requires
courage but also imagination and
curiosity about our fellow human beings
it rejects fear and suspicion it demands
that we listen to each other it measures
the limits of our humanity both Pauli
Murray and bill by Nikki drew such large
circles and so many circles that their
lives intersected I urge you to do the
same draw many circles make them large
in all kinds of ways you will find life
rich richer fuller and more meaningful
and you will bring to the world the
empathy and understanding we so
desperately need members of the class of
2018 it is time to leave the garden and
go into the woods please rise
as you go on to a world that is all
before you hand-in-hand with wandering
steps and slow bring to that world all
that your Yale education has given you
the ability to engage critically even
while listening respectfully to respond
creatively to challenges and obstacles
to embrace your responsibilities while
finding happiness and to draw ever wider
circle a circle of belonging the circles
of understanding in this world we're
delighted we are delighted to salute
your accomplishments and we are proud of
your achievements remember though to
give thanks for all that has brought you
to this day and go forth from this place
with grateful hearts paying back the
gifts you have received here by using
your minds your voices and your hands to
strengthen your new communities and the
world congratulations class of 2018
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
may God bless you and keep you may the
eternal show you favor and be gracious
to you may the Holy One cause light to
shine upon you and to grant you peace
and let us say Amen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]